ladies and gentlemen republicans have
suffered a completely
humiliating defeat last night losing
really badly their attempt to recall
democratic california governor gavin
newsom
and to replace him with there was really
only one person who might have replaced
newsome if the vote had gone yes on
recall rather than no
and that is the absolutely radical
republican named larry elder now we're
going to go through some different
aspects of this story here but the big
narrative is
mostly right wingers in california
despite claims that the left also isn't
happy with gavin newsom some democrats
not happy with gavin newsom but by and
large mostly the right wing of
california many of them pro-trump
decided to try to remove the governor
gavin newsom
the top alternative
was a republican named larry elder who
agrees with donald trump on 99 of
everything the only disagreement i was
able to find
between larry elder and donald trump was
that larry elder didn't like
the chinese tariffs that donald that
donald trump put in place but beyond
that this was a guy who was not only
pro-trump but in some cases even beyond
trump saying he would end every mask
requirement if he were to become
governor he would end every vaccine
requirement if he were to become
governor he has a long history of
deranged political statements um
misogynistic statements homophobic
statements racist statements even
and he got absolutely crushed in terms
of the first question the recalls are a
two-part question the first question is
should governor newsom be recalled
70 reporting this morning mail-in
ballots left to be counted but 64
of voters said no
newsome should not be recalled
uh basically a two to one loss for those
seeking to remove gavin newsom i mean
just a resounding and humiliating defeat
now had the recall gone yes remove gavin
newsom
then it would have gone to the second
question and it would have been larry
elder who became the governor of
california elder got 47 percent
of the question to vote
followed by friend of the show kevin
paffrath who ran as a democrat called
into the live stream we did last night
nice guy uh although my position all
along has been just vote no do not
recall gavin newsom so it was going to
be larry elder if newsom didn't stay now
this is a major bullet dodged and a
major humiliation for republicans and
this is also to some degree a referendum
on trumpism
this entire take them out attitude
replace them with a pro-trump republican
this is to some degree a signal about
the power of trumpism which may be we
don't we don't know yet
the power of trumpism may be diminishing
we won't really know until november of
2022 but it is a good sign
that this movement failed and failed so
miserably at attempting to replace the
sitting democratic governor with a
trumpian lunatic republican in larry
elder now what exactly happened here how
did this all end up the way it ended up
well remember that early on and we have
the polling a trajectory for this race
up on the screen now for people who are
watching early on there was a long
period of time about three full weeks in
august where the polling was almost
completely tied and we were worried
about that it was it was it wasn't too
close it was tied between keep and
remove gavin newsom but two different
things were going on first in a recall
the people wanting the recall
are often more engaged for a period of
time since everybody else is just living
their lives they're not looking to be
involved in a recall this isn't a
scheduled election and so as more and
more californians learned about the
recall and its paramount importance
you saw more and more say no i'm
actually going to get involved i'm a
likely voter now and i want to keep
gavin newsom
secondly the most important issue for
recall voters was covid and so as larry
elder explained he said i would get rid
of every guideline around kovid as delta
grew in august larry elder's cartoonish
position on covid only helped gavin
newsom even more and ultimately it went
very much in gavin newsom's favor let's
look at a couple of different clips here
is fox news
eventually calling it i think this was
after 1am um dave wasserman called this
at like 11 15
eastern time i think this was like
around 1am
um this was fox news calling it last
night now steve stand by because the
associated press has now just called it
you see the numbers on the bottom of
your screen see the check mark there
67.3 32
yes that means that gavin newsom will
not be recalled the associated press has
now called it you've got 58 percent of
the vote in there it is and actually
that may have been earlier and then
larry elder eventually came out and
spoke this may have been around 1am
eastern elder finally saying
we may have lost the battle but we have
not lost the war let's be gracious let's
be gracious in defeat
[Applause]
and by the way
we may have lost
the
battle but we are going to win the war
so at the end of the day
this was just a bad idea
and it was an expenditure of political
capital
for doing nothing other than being
resoundly defeated and spending more
than 250 million dollars to do this this
optional recall election which wasn't
even close there was no shot at removing
uh gavin newsom
250 million dollars the very same people
complaining about profligate government
spending
acted to spend 250 million dollars on an
election that ended up humiliating them
and also was completely unnecessary now
there are some right wingers who are
turning around and saying this failed
because california's full of stupid
liberals
just get out of california and ben
shapiro basically tweeted as much last
night saying quote the failure of the
california recall is a reminder to
republicans still in the state
the decline is now inexorable
get out while the getting is good and
move to a purple or red state your life
will radically
improve well that's fine and let's see
if people do it we have freedom of
movement in the united states between
states the california exodus that
they've been claiming is going on for a
long time hasn't actually been going on
and they also for being free marketeers
they seem to miss the fact that the
reason in part that things are expensive
in california is because there's a lot
of demand to live in california in those
parts much of california is actually
dirt cheap if you get away from the
popular areas on the coast and some
inland cities there's a lot of
california that is really really cheap
why is it so expensive to live in santa
barbara a tiny city of 90 000 people
versus just to pick a place with a
similar population parma ohio
maybe you've never heard of parma ohio
maybe you have
the reason santa barbara is more
expensive is because more people want to
live in santa barbara because it's nicer
with better schools access to better
airports better infrastructure and
california ranks fifth in healthcare
compared to ohio at 37th this is the
market because more people want to live
in santa barbara than in parma
that drives prices up
because there's a limited supply of
housing and space and jobs in santa
barbara if the politics of california
disgust people and they move out demand
will go down and it'll get cheaper and
wherever those people go
demand will go up and it will get more
expensive if all the people wanting to
live in santa barbara
go
and live in parma ohio parma ohio will
become more expensive i don't know if
health care will get any better maybe
over time with additional tax revenue
who knows but this is sort of like the
way the market works and these people
seem to very much not understand it so a
disaster disaster for republicans in
california let's hope it's a sign of
things to come in the 2022 midterms but
house races
in florida are very different than a
recall election in a full state election
like california so let's not get ahead
of ourselves
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
the only subscription streaming service
that focuses exclusively on
documentaries if you love documentaries
the way i do you're missing out if you
don't have a subscription to curiosity
stream i love it for one reason it has
the biggest best selection of
documentaries that you'll find anywhere
including the newest popular ones that
everybody's talking about and most of it
is stuff you really can't find on other
streaming services last month they added
a ton of great new documentaries to the
library one i watched is brimstone and
glory
about a pyrotechnic festival in mexico
random but fascinating curiosity stream
is giving my audience 25 off meaning you
can subscribe for just 15 bucks a year
not a big price tag relative to the
hours and hours of enjoyment i know you
will get from curiositystream
just go to
curiositystream.com pacman the link is
right underneath this video